- [Instructor] Hydrochloric
acid is an example
of a strong acid,
and sodium hydroxide is an
example of a strong base.
When an aqueous solution
of hydrochloric acid reacts
with an aqueous solution
of sodium hydroxide,
the products are an aqueous solution
of sodium chloride and water.
Since the reaction goes to completion,
instead of an equilibrium arrow,
there's just an arrow going to the right.
And this is called an acid-base
neutralization reaction.
Let's think about the
ions that are involved
in this acid-base neutralization reaction.
Since hydrochloric acid is a strong acid,
HCl ionizes 100% in solution,
and therefore, in solution,
HCl consists of H plus
ions and Cl minus anions.
Sodium hydroxide is a strong base,
and strong bases dissociate
100% in solution.
Therefore, an aqueous solution
of sodium hydroxide consists
of sodium ions, Na plus, and
hydroxide anions, OH minus.
For our products,
sodium chloride is a soluble salt
and therefore forms an aqueous solution.
So in solution, we would
have sodium cations, Na plus,
and chloride anions, Cl minus.
Since water ionizes only
to a very small extent,
we don't write it as the ions,
we simply write H2O.
To save some time,
I went ahead and added
in aqueous subscripts,
and for water, it'd be liquid,
and some plus signs
and the reaction arrow.
This is called the overall ionic equation
for our strong acid-strong base reaction.
Instead of calling it an
overall ionic equation,
we could also call it a
complete ionic equation.
And we can use the overall ionic equation
to determine the net ionic equation
for this strong acid-strong base reaction.
To figure out the net ionic equation,
we first need to determine
the spectator ions.
Remember, spectator ions don't participate
in the chemical reaction.
Notice how we have a sodium
cation on the reactant side
and a sodium cation on the product side,
so we can cancel out the sodium cation.
We also have a chloride
anion on the reactant side
and a chloride anion on the product side.
So we can cross that ion out as well.
So the sodium cation
and the chloride anion
are the spectator ions.
And once we take out our spectator ions,
we're left with the net ionic equation.
So for the net ionic equation,
we would have H plus,
plus OH minus yields H2O.
So this is one way of writing
our net ionic equation.
However, remember that H plus and H3O plus
are used interchangeably in chemistry.
So instead of writing H plus
in our net ionic equation,
we could have also written H3O plus,
and when H3O plus, or the hydronium ion,
reacts with the hydroxide anion,
we still form water.
But notice, for this version
of the net ionic equation,
we need to put a two as a
coefficient to balance everything.
Next, let's think about a situation
where we have equal
moles of our strong acid
and strong base.
For example,
let's say we have one mole of HCl
and one mole of NaOH.
To help us think about what's
happening in this situation,
we're gonna use an ICF table,
where I stands for the
initial number of moles,
C stands for the change in moles,
and F stands for the
final amount of moles.
The reason why we're using an ICF table
instead of an ICE table
is in an ICE table,
the E stands for equilibrium,
and here we assume the
reaction goes to completion.
Therefore, instead of E,
we're writing F for final amount of moles.
Let's fill out the rest of our ICF table.
We have the initial amount
of moles of HCL and NaOH,
and if we assume the
reaction hasn't happened yet,
the initial amount of moles
of NaCl would be zero.
Looking at the balanced equation,
one mole of HCl reacts with
one mole of sodium hydroxide.
And since the reaction goes to completion,
we can go ahead and write,
under the change part here,
we're gonna react one mole of HCl,
so we're gonna lose that one mole of HCl.
And since it's a one-to-one ratio,
we're gonna lose one mole of NaOH.
And since there's a one as a
coefficient in front of NaCl,
under the change part on our ICF table,
we would write plus one mole for NaCl.
Since we started with one mole
of HCl, and we lost one mole,
the final amount of moles
for HCl would be zero.
Same thing for sodium hydroxide,
the final amount of moles would be zero,
because it's one minus one.
For NaCl, we started off
with zero and we gained one.
So we're ending up with
a final amount of moles
of one mole of sodium chloride.
So when the reaction goes to completion,
the strong acid and the strong base
have completely neutralized each other.
And essentially, we
have an aqueous solution
of sodium chloride.
At 25 degrees Celsius,
the pH of water is seven,
which is neutral,
and the sodium cations
and the chloride anions
do not react with water,
so they don't affect the pH.
Therefore, for the situation
where you have equal amount
of moles of a strong
acid and a strong base,
the pH of the resulting
solution will be seven.
Let's do another strong
acid-strong base calculation.
However, this time,
the moles of strong acid and
strong base are not equal.
So let's say we react 300 milliliters
of a 1.0 molar solution of HCl
with 100 milliliters
of a 1.0 molar solution
of sodium hydroxide.
And our goal is to calculate the pH
of the resulting solution.
And I should point out
these are aqueous solutions
of HCl and NaOH.
The first step is to
calculate moles of strong acid
and moles of strong base.
And the equation for molarity
is equal to moles over liters.
So for our strong acid,
HCl, the molarity is 1.0,
and the volume is 300 milliliters,
which is equal to .300 liters.
So solving for x, we find that x
is equal to .30 moles of HCl.
For our strong base, sodium hydroxide,
the concentration is one molar,
and the volume is 100 milliliters,
which is equal to .100 liters.
So solving for x,
we find that x is equal
to .10 moles of NaOH.
Going back to HCl,
since HCl is strong
acid that ionizes 100%,
if we have .30 moles of HCl,
we have .30 moles of H plus ions,
or we could say .30 moles
of hydronium ions, H3O plus.
And for sodium hydroxide,
since sodium hydroxide is a strong base
that dissociates 100%,
if we have .10 moles of sodium hydroxide,
we have .10 moles of sodium ions
and also .10 moles of
hydroxide ions, OH minus.
And if we think about
our net ionic equation,
the .30 moles of hydronium
ions will react with
the .10 moles of hydroxide ions.
So here's one way to write
our net ionic equation.
The hydronium ion plus the
hydroxide ion forms 2H2O.
And to help us find the pH,
we're gonna use another ICF table.
The initial moles of hydronium ions,
we calculated to be .30,
and the initial moles of hydroxide ions,
we calculated to be .10.
Because we don't have
equal amounts of moles
and the mole ratio is one to one.
In this case,
we're gonna have a limiting
reactant and an excess reactant.
Since we only have .10
moles of hydroxide ions,
all of the hydroxide ions will react.
And since it's a one-to-one mole ratio,
.10 moles of hydroxide ions
will react with .10 moles
of hydronium ions,
so we can write minus .10
under hydronium as well.
Therefore, when the
reaction goes to completion,
for the hydroxide ions,
we'll have used all of them up.
We started with .10
and we're using up .10,
therefore, we'll have zero moles.
For the hydronium ion,
we started with .30 moles
minus .10 gives us .20 moles.
So the hydroxide ions were
our limiting reactant,
and the hydronium ions
where our excess reactant.
So the strong base neutralized
some of the strong acid
that was present,
and we can calculate the pH
of the resulting solution
by the number of moles
of excess hydronium ions.
Next, we calculate the concentration
of hydronium ions in solution.
Since the number of moles
of hydronium ions is .20,
we plug that into our
equation for molarity,
so molarity is equal to moles over liters,
and the total volume of our solution
will be 300 milliliters
plus 100 milliliters,
which is 400 milliliters, or .400 liters.
So let me go and write this in here.
So .20 moles divided by .400 liters
is equal to a concentration of .50 molar.
And because the pH is
equal to the negative log
of the concentration of hydronium ions,
if we plug in our concentration
of hydronium ions of .50,
the pH is equal to the
negative log of .50,
which is equal to .30.
Having a low pH for our resulting solution
at 25 degrees Celsius
makes a lot of sense,
because we ended up
with an excess of acid.